l'open de france se déroule seulement en
juillet mais c'est dès maintenant que le
parcours de l'albatros se met en forme
cette opération d'entretien dit de
carottage se décompose en trois phases
une première machine répond le sable sur
chaque trou du parcours
la seconde étape revient à ce tracteur
armée du carottage ces grands pics perse
la terre enfin cette voiture verte
faisant office de dameuses infiltre le
sable dans les trous ces petites
trousses on parle est rempli avec les
sables à cana mauvaise où il va
permettre les auxiliaires et d aller à
la racine de dotation en même temps avec
la pluie et ça va augmenter la capacité
des drainages en l'espace d'un mois
trois mille tonnes de sable seront
déversées sur les 150 hectares du
parcours pour cet entretien il faut
absolument des conditions climatiques
sèches
l'objectif obtenir le meilleur fairway
possible pour l'open de france vers le
web pour le mois si on fait un film très
fine
c'est un fait ou un uniforme avec les
mines limited deir ezzor est
et pour tous les faits loin avec une
personne très fine et qui a les faits il
ya vraiment verticale une vingtaine de
personnes s'affairent à redonner vie aux
féroé évidemment jouer au golf entre les
tracteurs n'est pas idéal pour tout
joueur qui se respecte
alors pendant cette période ils
bénéficient d'une réduction de 10 % sur
le tarif du parcours qu'ils se rassurent
le sable aura disparu d'ici dix à vingt
jours